Okay, South Carolina.
This is why it is so important for us to stay vigilant
on what is happening in our state
when it comes to women's reproductive health,
because it is becoming increasingly obvious
that this is a war against women.
I just Learned that Republican lawmakers
have reintroduced the Equal Prenatal Rights Protection Act,
which would classify an unborn fetus as a person
in the state of South Carolina,
which means that women can be charged with murder
for seeking abortion care.
And you ask yourself, hmm,
does South Carolina have the death penalty?
Yes, we do.
And it calls into question how we
as women
are gonna be able to be able to trust our medical professionals,
because they could rat us into the police.
And what kind of doctors gonna be left in a state like this?
And the other thought I had is,
as a Jewish woman, this goes against my religious freedom,
because Jewish people do not believe that life begins at conception.
We believe life begins at first breath.
So call your representatives!
Make noise! Okay,
we gotta get this out of here.